after the Red Wave washes over us on
Tuesday the Democrats will of course
respond by refusing to look inward or
engage in anything like introspection
they will Lament The Death of democracy
they'll accuse Republicans of cheating
Even after spending years claiming that
it's an attack on Democracy to accuse
your opponent of cheating they will
blame the American people they'll blame
racism homophobia transphobia
Arachnophobia all the phobias they'll
say and do many things but one thing
they will not do is spend any time
trying to actually figure out why they
lost and lost so badly if they did
they would see that one of the most
catastrophic mistakes was to make
abortion a central part of their
campaign message they assumed that
voters would be motivated you know by
the overturning of Roe they assumed
Americans would flock to the polls to
defend the right to kill babies they
assumed that most Americans are as
avidly supportive of baby murder as they
are
and they assumed wrongly
but this is the horse they rode in on
and they're going to take it all the way
to the Finish Line regardless in the
final days before the election every
Democratic apparatus is leaning into the
pro-abortion message in ways that range
from unintentionally hilarious to
unbelievably heinous so we'll kind of
ease into this and we'll start with the
hilarious first so over on NBC
the medical drama New Amsterdam which is
a show that apparently exists aired an
episode this week revolving around
um abortion and the overturning of Roe
the daily wire reports quote
the recent episode maybe tomorrow
explores a world with restricted access
to abortion showrunners spoke with TV
line about their motivations and aims
for the episode which had left his fans
applauding and conservatives swearing
that they're done with the series
forever the episode begins with a
montage showing Hospital staff realizing
Roe v Wade had been overturned which was
presented as a catastrophic event
each character then dealt with the
aftermath in their own way Dr Lauren
Bloom uh played by Janet Montgomery
admits that she had an abortion in the
past which was not a big deal quote
unquote one doctor punched a protester
outside the hospital and New Amsterdam
staffers panic because he's gay and
they're concerned about the Court's
outlawing same-sex marriage at various
points in the episode Max inquires about
opening an abortion clinic on a military
base and setting up a floating Clinic to
circumvent new laws quote these kinds of
issues both in our country in the
healthcare industry is why I wrote the
show to begin with it's why I created
New Amsterdam according to David
Schoener the showrunner which she said
to TV line and interview as depressing
and horrifying as it was the show was
made to tackle these issues and so we
all put in everything we had into this
episode
yes they put everything they had into it
unfortunately that that means that they
didn't put any you know intelligence or
subtlety or wit into it because they
didn't have any uh to begin with which
explains the opening scene as mentioned
in the daily wire article okay it's the
the Montage opening scene and it is it
is honestly
one of the greatest scenes of
unintentional comedy to ever air on
television I mean the whole thing plays
like a parody and when I first saw this
I had to I had to watch it all the way
through and I'm and I'm I'm waiting for
the punch line and it never came
because this is meant to be taken
seriously and you really just have to
see it to appreciate it so let's watch a
little bit of this together
okay so he's reading the news about Roe
v Wade big overturned
he's he's tearful
and he's looking at his daughter
[Music]
that young child will never be able to
kill a child and he's that that
he's distraught by that by that
possibility
he drops the phone he can't even look at
the foot he drops into disgusting
then we've got the people standing
around the street and they're just
they're dumbfounded because Roe Vue was
ever turned shell-shocked and she drops
she drops the cup they do the dramatic
cup drop
which has been a cliche since like 1995
by the way
and look at all these people walking
down the street every single one of them
I can't believe it
I can't believe they can't kill babies
anymore
you know this is New York and they can
still kill babies so
maybe someone could tell them that make
them feel better
oh and there's another father
he's in tears
he sent his father is in tears because
his uh he's thinking about uh you know
that his daughter will never be able to
kill his grandchildren and that actually
makes him cry
so the whole scene when it went on for
like two minutes sending data over an
unencrypted internet connection is like
sending a postcard your message is wide
open for the mailman and any other nosy
individual to see whether you're
connected to an unencrypted internet
Network on your phone computer tablet or
TV you're sending countless pieces of
information out into the digital world
that can be seen and intercepted by
pretty much anyone a VPN creates a
secure tunnel between you and uh your
between your device and the Internet
it's like putting your postcard in an
envelope so that no one can read your
letter before it gets to the person
you're sending it to expressvpn is the
VPN I trust to keep my data secure
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your personal data your passwords your
financial details Etc hackers make
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn makes it easier than ever
just to keep your information safe
that's all you got to do is fire up the
app click one button and you're
instantly protected plus expressvpn
works on all your devices so you can
stay secure on the go secure enjoy your
online data today at expressvpn.com Matt
walshow and get three extra months free
that's expressvpn.com Matt
walshowexpressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
there was a time
when
something so heavy-handed and on the
nose and corny and cliche ridden again
we you actually get the scene where the
person is holding a cup of coffee and
dramatically drops it
there was a time when something like
that that could only exist in the
Christian movie space
okay uh though coming from the opposite
ideological perspective but modern
Hollywood has now adopted the same
approach as the Christian film industry
except without the benefit of at least
being right about the issues
if you want to know why Democrats are
about to lose it's because they think
that that what you just watched is an
effective piece of propaganda
when it comes to politics there is
nothing worse than being unintentionally
funny in a political setting you never
want to be that's the worst thing you
could be is unintentionally funny look
at Joe Biden he's unintentionally funny
all the time
uh because then you've made yourself
into a joke
that's the Democratic specialty at this
point
and yet it was not all fun and games
also this week NPR did its own bit of
pro-abortion propagandizing while taking
a decidedly different approach
again this is from the daily wire it
says NPR's Michigan Morning Edition
aired in aired in abortion on air
Thursday morning complete with the sound
of the 11 week old pre-born child being
vacuumed from the womb reporter Katie
Wells narrated the account of the
unnamed woman undergoing the abortion at
Northland Family Planning in the Detroit
area quote abortion clinics are almost
always closed to the Press but a group
of Michigan clinics generously allowed
us to embed with them because abortion
rights are on the ballot in Michigan
this November but for the doctors staff
and patients we met there none of this
was about politics Wells wrote in
October during her investigation for the
patients who allowed us into their lives
and their procedures it's about whether
they could Escape an abusive partner or
support the kids they already have or
finish school or keep their jobs we're
going to take you inside the clinic she
added for nine days ahead of the midterm
elections Wells shared stories from her
investigation into in a lengthy article
one account spoke of a woman named
Melissa from Ohio who came to Michigan
for an abortion Ohio recently enacted a
ban on most abortions after six to
pregnancy quote I would be struggling
for a very long time Melissa said I
would have to drop out of school and I
would have to find a different job
because I would need more daycare she
opted to go through with an abortion at
14 weeks of pregnancy
okay so they played the actual audio
of an abortion and I have that clip I'm
not going to play the whole thing
um because I'm you know you have to
decipher yourself if you want to
actually listen to it but
instead we'll play you the the lead up
okay right right up to the moment when
they turn the abortion machine on uh so
I'll play that much at least and here it
is listen
patient is not one of the patients you
heard before she's asked that we not use
her name she's from Michigan she already
has one kid she's having her abortion at
about 11 weeks nearly all abortions in
Michigan are before 13 weeks unlike many
patients at Northland she said I could
record her procedure we're going to hear
some of that now so I am just going to
get you set up on the table and we're
going to
do your legs most patients are partially
awake during the procedures they get IV
medication for pain and anxiety the
lights are dimmed they're soothing music
it actually feels a lot like a
childbirth the medical gown your bare
legs and stirrups and a person next to
you saying you can do this
deep breathing
that's Brandy she's one of the staffers
her job is to monitor vital signs but it
is also to hold the patient's hand and
talk her through this
whether it's a birth or an abortion it
is often women guiding other women we're
going to hear this machine turn on now
pig makes a loud noise
well that machine is the vacuum that is
used to suck the baby out of the womb
ripping him apart in the process
um the sound of the vacuum is Eerie for
the obvious reasons that it's being used
to murder a child
and also because without that sound the
whole thing would sound very similar to
a childbirth the abortionist urging
haran you know encouraging her saying
keep breathing as she says throughout
the quote procedure at the end if you
listen all the way to the end you can
hear people in the room laughing and
smiling and saying you did great
this is the point that NPR wants us to
take away that's why they recorded and
aired it in the first place they're
saying see you know abortion isn't scary
it's just like childbirth
except that it's the opposite of
childbirth it is like a satanic parody
of childbirth
to treat the murder of a child as though
it is the birth of a child
that doesn't make the murder better or
more palatable if anything it makes it
worse
if it's possible for it to be worse than
it already is then that would be the
effect here
this should really tell you what you
need to know the NBC and NPR propaganda
given to us in the same week
also gives us a look at the at the two
ends of the abortion propaganda Spectrum
there's abortion as portrayed in this
fictionalized universe on NBC and then
there's abortion as it is in reality
which NPR let us listen to
the former the fictionalized version is
inevitably ridiculous and the latter no
matter what they do or how they try to
address it up
it is inevitably horrific and
gut-wrenching
which is why they rarely do this they
rarely give you a look inside when it's
actually happening
and I can tell you that I guarantee NPR
is already regretting their decision
here
you know we're supposed to hear the
sounds of a woman having her baby killed
and think hey that's not so bad
but instead we're viscerally repulsed
and horrified
because there is no appealing or
credible way to present this abortion is
what it is in the end
and what it is is the direct and
intentional murder of innocent human
life
nothing will ever make that okay
and the Democrats I think will pay the
price as they should politically
for pinning their electoral hopes on it
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to our members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday have a great weekend
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]